foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I'm Piers Morgan uncensored tonight
ecozealous plot to disrupt the London
marathon after wrecking the snooker and
invading the Grand National and
apparently threatening to do the same
with the coronation but the public and
every political party already backed
their cause so what are they doing
Sam Smith unites parents four clutches
and pop fans in horror with an x-rated
Global tour are they as he calls himself
testing the limits of artistic
expression or are they a ghastly
attention-seeking bomber-inducing weirdo
we will debate plus the shocking
absurdity of Britain's Asylum system lay
bare Albanian gangsters living in hotels
but an Afghan war veteran who flew
combat missions with us against the
Taliban is facing deportation to Rwanda
how can that be right I'm Gonna Save him
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening
uncensored a whopping 74 of British
adults say they're worried about climate
change as am I every major political
party agrees and has a plan to spend
billions on fixing it 97 of publishing
scientists say humans are warming up the
planet with serious consequences that's
undeniable these are numbers that even
Kim Jong-un could only dream about so
what exactly is the point of this
oh look at this
that's a just stop oil protester and
there was another one there as well
wrecking the snooker at The Crucible on
Monday night a professional imbecile who
mounted the table tossed orange powder
everywhere shrieked dementedly to a
mostly working-class crowd of sports fan
who'd probably spent most of the Year
saving up to be at snooker's big event I
would wage every penny in Elon musk's
bank account the precisely none of them
not any of the many millions watching at
home watched that ridiculous performance
and thought Oh yeah wow that really
makes you want to support just up oil
this is the same band of selfish mainly
middle-class twerks who risks their
lives and the safety of many other
people by disrupting the British Grand
Prix they've regularly shut down
motorways and block roads they've glued
themselves to Priceless artworks they've
coated Ferrari and Aston Martin
showrooms in paint they threw tomato
soup at a van Gogh
and they've interrupted football matches
by strapping themselves to the goal
posts they're a campaign Group which is
attempting to persuade the public to
agree with them about something they
already agree with and they're basically
doing stuff now to annoy the public as
much as they possibly can to stop the
public enjoying things or going about
their daily lives and if that is
seriously your strategy I would argue
you have Net Zero brain cells the fact
is that Britain has a comparatively good
record now on climate change the world's
biggest polluters like China Russia have
diabolical records have you ever seen
Greta Thornburg in Moscow or Beijing or
a single just up oil protester in either
of those places or even outside the
Chinese Embassy here
well apparently one or two of them have
popped along there
but what they don't do is what they do
to our lives anywhere where the real
polluters lie and their partners in
crime Extinction Rebellion are planning
to disrupt the London Marathon this
weekend we're told another Bunch animal
Rising invaded the Grand National last
weekend causing such a commotion that
one of the horse trainers actually
directly blamed the commotion for the
death of their horse
well today uh this whining video is
released about the robust response of
those ancientry protesters met from
local police
their police officers were laughing at
me and calling other police officers
over and saying oh my God look at this
look at the state of this this is
hilarious and although I couldn't see I
could hear clicking and it was like they
were taking pictures of me the officer
pulling my hair was obviously behind me
and I couldn't read her badge number so
I asked her to identify herself multiple
times to which she just kept repeating
you're you're screaming in my uh the
other officers carrying me similarly
refused to identify her so I have no way
to follow this up
did she pull your hair
oh no really you poor little chap
I think that police officer spoke for
all of us
he's a well joining me now is James
skeet from just a Boyle a fellow
environmental campaigner Danica McCarthy
okay uh my feelings pretty clear here's
the problem I have with it with this
just up oil thing is that
most people agree with the issue that
you're campaigning for most people in
the polls think there's a real problem
with climate change I'm one of them no
arguments for that but most people in
fact the vast majority now are
absolutely sick and tired of what just
stop oil are doing they think it's
Purell pathetic and it's not advancing
the cause one eye under nobody is
walking around going God they've rightly
they've wrecked the snooker I must come
around to their cause why do this stuff
I don't get it well just the
transparency peers
um you've signed a deal for 50 million
pounds for this show I don't know what
deal or so you've signed a deal for 50
minutes
who sits on the board of Genie oil and
gas
um so just for transparency just so
we're all aware that that's what I do
work for murder yes you do he owns this
network yes and he's spent decades
persuading the British people and uh
this is around the world me asking you
about the merits of wrecking regular
life for britons in this country I don't
get it for example do you support what
happened at the snooker
of course I support what happens at the
snook why why are you laughing I'm am I
laughing yeah you are you're smirking
and so was the guy who did the the stand
up okay here's my problem it's all a bit
of a game for you guys you regularly you
regularly get seen smoking and laughing
it's all a bit of fun it's not fun for
the people whose lives you're ruining
appears
um when the last ipcc report was
released and that's basically the sound
of the world's climate scientists
banging their heads against the desks
basically in despair that no one's
listening to them that made page 11 of
the Daily Mail underneath two women
arguing over their geraniums right
as a result of what happened on Monday
our demand has been on the front of
everything no your demand wasn't on the
front page that idiot was on the front
page millions millions of conversations
millions of conversations have been
elicited and if even a tenth of them
um draw attention to the fact that the
British government are plowing ahead
with over 100 new fossil fuel licenses
opening new coal mines in the middle of
the worst crisis that we've ever seen
then it's a win don't you think do you
think no I don't I don't think it's a
win at all I think I think it's a
massive lose actually I think what
you're doing is alienating a public who
might well be persuaded because they
show it in the polls to come on your
side but at the moment they think you're
a bunch of annoying twerks wrecking
their lives let me bring in uh you here
I don't understand
why you can't because you're you're not
an unintelligent person I've followed
your stuff for a few years why you can't
understand that this is backfiring why
you don't get that the British public
are sick of it I think what's really
interesting here is is that you've just
spent five minutes talking about tactics
when you actually said you are you're
seriously concerned about this issue
yeah we would really welcome
conversations on talk TV about the
issues you said you know the British
government is doing good well actually a
report came out last week from Iran
about global investment in new fossil
fuels since Copenhagen six trillion
dollars invested in new fossil fuels 15
came from the UK
I think I'm going to give you a
follow-up question
I need to finish the point Guardsmen
tell me the carbon emissions that the UK
and then for China and Russia and India
Britain is investing 15 of the global
investment in fossil fuels globally
which according to the International
Energy agency according to in the
European Investment Bank and even HSBC
are saying we do not need investing
seven trillion dollars over the next 10
years is a suicide note for Humanity
okay so you're not talking about that so
you say uh but I'll ask you again so do
the world scientists okay yes but there
is actually a very debatable uh response
for masand is about exactly the best way
to tackle this because I would listen to
a woman for example on Nick Ferrari shot
LBC the other day saying that within
eight years if we stopped awarding any
licenses now we'd have eight more years
of gas and oil and then she said we
could actually sustain this country for
all the power we need from wind and
waves that's what we're saying it's
completely unworkable there is nobody
with a brain who has managed to work out
a way so that could possibly be done in
eight years do you actually so so you
guys are living do you believe guys are
living in no no sorry cheers are you
saying the European Investment Bank h
HSBC the International Energy agency
knows more than you because that what I
am saying is quoting them I'm not saying
they know more than me no I'm telling
them they are actually saying you can't
invest in new fossil fuels because we've
got enough muscles they're sensible to
ask for efficient in my estimation the
sensible way to do this is to move
slowly off fossil fuels to renewable
energy yes to make it affordable and
make it practical we don't have half the
country turned into wind funds that's
the sensible way to do this right and
I'm up for that sensible debate that's
not why you two are booked on this show
you two were booked on this show because
the methods that you're using in my
opinion are now damaging your cause they
are actually deterring the public for
supporting you and again I ask you why
do it why break the snooker why go and
shots
why is the government investing massive
amounts and new fossil fuels when the
United says we can't afford it right why
is the government saying one thing
you're playing what a battery my
question is my question is core to this
issue
and in my long time in the media I can
tell you it's not going to work the very
fact that we're having this conversation
is a testament to the efficacy of these
things
brought on the British is your
sophisticated scientific opinion about
climate change
you've been brought some because your
idiot friends have been once again
wrecking things for people the fact of
that is that we're seeing that the only
real leverage that normal people have is
through disruptive tactics right the
nurses know it the train drivers know it
the junior so why don't you go where the
real polluters are why don't you go to
Beijing because we wanted to go to
Russia
telling people what to do you are moral
cowards your moral cowards it's easier
to go and ruin an old granny's day at
The Crucible than it is to get on a
plane and go to Beijing
until the eighth biggest emitter
historically we have to get our own
house in order before we go around the
world lecture I've asked I've asked I've
asked you if and I'll ask you what do
you think
why don't you go to Sudan hang on why
don't you go to Pakistan interview the
people whose life okay
listen and use your amazing rules
courageous just to verify it's not your
show no but shout out I do work I do the
questions stop shouting at me then you
haven't answered my conversation let's
have a question that's good see if you
can answer it what are the CO2 emissions
for this country and what are they for
China and Russia and India per capita
not that Capital what are the emissions
what percentage of the emissions in the
world are you come from China you think
China using childish maths is silly
childish math yes a statistical fact
because no a country that's bigger than
UK what's the percentage of the global
emissions are you talking about come
from China production emissions are
consumption just give me the emissions
you are
what I am saying is China is 20 times
bigger in population the UK so its
emissions are 20 times bigger but our
investments are 15 times when are you
going to Beijing when you go to to Sudan
play it amazing can we can we agree I'll
put you guys on a plane tomorrow to
basically I'll pay right people are you
going to go and protests
I just think you guys are honestly
moronic in the way you're going about
this if you want to go Tango doesn't
come with us to Pakistan come with us to
Sudan and talk to them talk to people
who are dying how are you going to get
there this is like the usual yeah you
just invited me to Beijing and I said
I'll go there how are you going to get
this I will fly to Pakistan okay so you
believe in flights that's a child well
you've been I don't fly for a holidays
to you you've been on that's like for
holidays you've been on National
Television I'll watch this interview you
went on my old program Good Morning
Britain and you you actually said you
wanted everyone to get rid of their pets
you are the great pets Lord you want to
fly take a look let's take a look do you
fly for a holiday say hello you're just
playing the person not not the actual
issues
as well I mean it's it's one thing to
give up your car but you're not going to
give up a loved member of your family
which frankly is what people consider
cats and dogs
well if we love our members of our
family if we love our kids do you have
success we have to look after the
climate crisis
firstly I want to look after my kids and
my pets that's what that's shopping
that's quite shocking do you understand
the level of prices that the carbon
emissions are currently in the planet we
all think I shouldn't be looking after
my children and my pets
I'm saying that to look after and love
your children you have to look after
your carbon emissions people dying in
Sudan and the people drowning just to be
clarified no one can hear you and but
that was airing uh that was you saying
we should all get rid of our pets
do you stand by that hang on let him
answer you said that on national TV but
I stand by you stand by we should all
get rid of it I stand by such you should
look at the women who are dying in Sudan
do you answer questions you ask the
question I'm here is this for journalism
when you're not hacking into murder
children's funds oh okay so
unfortunately you've just committed a
very serious libel because that was
another newspaper which if you were
slightly more intelligent and well
informed you would have known that
allegation which is made against me most
days on Twitter by idiots like you is
actually a disgusting lie so here's your
chance to now apologize for a disgusting
lie you're prepared to do that
absolutely not okay well then I would if
I were you I'd have a chat with your
lawyers after the show and see how they
React to what you think so do you think
we should be having grown-up
conversation about it
well I don't think stealing I don't
think just feeling disgusting the family
lies about something that I had nothing
to do well you've tried
a grown-up situation I agree you want to
talk about great situation
with the reality of what's Happening
Here I'm not asking you I've got four
children and you don't if you could like
if you could sit back what I think
you've said enough for the last five
minutes uh-huh let me ask you don't like
it do you stand by your claim that we
should get rid of all the pets I I did
not ever say that I didn't say it I was
actually that it was actually what an
irrelevant discussion you think that's
irrelevant to a nation of pet love hang
on I did not say that first of all and
secondly trying to play the billions of
people playing the personals have you
ever watched you want to save the human
beings and get rid of all the million
people would displaced last time yeah 60
UK families lost their houses in
wildfires there's a result of 25 000
wildflowers when we hit 40 degrees and
you're not emotionally connecting with
the reality of this at all I'm obviously
connecting with you I think
you do your little silly sound bites for
Twitter and Twitter goes oh look at my
little hero where's the rest of the
public watching go is who is this little
brat I wish those guys that jump on
snooker tables it's those guys that ruin
the ground now it's those guys that do
all this stuff
do you want to try and get in because
this guy's just I think he's gonna be
really useful rather than actually all
of us in indulging in personal attacks
is if we could have a serious battle
invite the oil companies in here Pierce
but you understand how hard it is
feeling this kind of stuff inviting the
old companies
unfortunately James you are a complete
what's the evidence could you
accept that the evidence is what the
viewers would be watching they just
think
and you're talking about stuff I
actually do wonder I actually do wonder
what kind of humanity would be left if
people like you were the only ones left
honestly it would be like a place I mean
a place where you're not allowed pets
that's a place where people like you are
running the country I would literally
rather die anyway it's been lovely
catching up thank you thank you very
much for your time uncensored next uh
they are at it again Sam Smith has done
crowds will sexualized satanic inspired
performances on a new world tour
artistic genius gay icon or attention
seeking Loom what about that
thank you
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it well that one two
[Music]
thank you thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
well that was a quiet start to the
evening proceedings uh welcome back Sam
Smith is back again with more
attention-seeking vulgarity uh they're
never one to do things quietly in recent
years we have to remember call him they
they're them even though there's only
one of them I remember the latex balloon
at the Brits
but they've taken things up a notch
haven't they with their new Global tour
criticized as hyper-sexualized and
satanic and apologize if you're easily
offended for what you're about to see
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
yeah exactly well joining me now is
comedian James Barr and best-selling
author of The Madness of crowns Douglas
Murray well Douglas let me start with
you uh I don't get this Sam Smith thing
it just seems like every week he
deliberately babe I'm sorry they even
though there's only one of them
why why is Sam Smith today no please do
address Douglas first but I just need to
just why is that's how they identify
that why is it why is one person they
because that's how they identify why
have I got to go along with it because
they've asked you to someone's asked me
even the pope respects people's pronouns
now I don't have to respect anybody's
pronouns well that's fine as long as I
make a decision my pronoun is hottest
man in the world yeah well I'm happy to
call you that some may disagree but yeah
if that's what you are then cool I will
address you as the hottest man in the
world throughout the entire throughout
the entire okay let's stick to that
Douglas let's come back to you uh you
don't have to call me the hottest man in
the world even if you're thinking
um Smith
to me he's just on an Ever deteriorating
campaign to be as vulgar and defensive
as he possibly can am I missing
something
uh he's doing what pop stars have done
for decades which is trying to shock as
a means to get publicity and of course
it's pretty successful I mean we're
talking about him at the moment uh but
it's it's striking that it's sort of
very unoriginal I mean all the stuff
he's doing the sort of over sexualized
stuff the sort of satanic stuff Madonna
did this 40 years ago
um uh you know pop stars have done this
and more for decades now uh I think the
only thing that Sam Smith has got sort
of going of him on this and the thing
actually is making people notice him on
this is that first of all he keeps sort
of throwing these bollards in the way of
everyone by changing his alleged gender
all the time yeah okay he came out some
years ago
he came he came out as many years ago as
gay and then he said he was actually uh
gender queer and then he said he was
non-binary and he said he didn't know
what it meant of course he didn't
because there's no such thing they but
he's he said that they were going to uh
he said that he thought he was gender
Quinn he didn't know what it meant but
he said that he would explain it someday
when he did know and I sort of think if
you're going to make everyone else
distort the language you should know
what you're talking about first so he
does that to get publicity obviously and
the other thing he does is he does this
sort of
um you know like taking all his clothes
off stuff and and the thing that makes
it different from other people is that
when oh I don't know Justin Timberlake
or Rihanna or someone stripped down they
do so because they look good like their
bodies look good Sam Smith is like pudgy
and very ugly and so people look at it
and he looks ridiculous and the problem
is is he's saying don't ridicule me but
it's hard not to ridicule people when
they present this is disgusting are you
talking about it on that point I
completely agree why say don't ridicule
me when you deliberately make yourself
look ridiculous no that is disgusting
that is a completely disgusting well
it's disgusting yeah we do find it
there's no what you're saying is why
we're allowed to find him no you are not
keep coming depending on what people
look like all the time if they're gonna
dress like that on a stage in front of
millions of people around the world
absolutely I can thank you for getting
the pronoun correct I really appreciate
that listen Douglas yes you did have you
cool have you called me mine hottest man
in the world because according to
someone and yourself
um listen the pope recently said they
completely accept every gender identity
and that everyone is a children why
should anyone be compelled to use a
pronoun from someone's identity three
times in three years
it's very important to note that other
pop stars have done this including Lewis
Capaldi who recently did a campaign
where he was naked on a billboard and
there were nowhere near as many vile
comments at Lewis Capaldi's body the
only reason you can't see any reason
there's a problem for Sam doing it is
because you aren't happy with his gender
identity because it makes you feel no I
don't care about his General identity I
just don't feel I can be compelled to
use pronouns I don't care about that's
fine don't use them if you don't want to
that's wrong you just told me I had to
no I think you should but if you don't
want to so I don't have a decision peers
shut up it's on Modest man alive right
okay right so changing your name now
you're no longer my body about Sam Smith
is is just an orgy of in my view
narcissistic self-indulgent deliberately
shocking stuff and Douglas has got point
he doesn't he looks terrible okay so why
would you do this you're friends with
Ozzy Osbourne right yeah Ozzy Osbourne
ate a bat's head on stage that could be
considered vulgar I mean he basically
never did anything like this he started
the covered pandemic and he can't
seriously Sam Smith getting there
serious you think what we're looking at
here is actually anything other than
ridiculous no I think it's absolutely
fantastic really yeah I do I think it's
brilliant I think it's sexy if you think
that's sexy that is the thing what we're
looking at right now is sexy yes I do
yeah seriously would you shag it
would I shag it did you say
well there's a question yeah absolutely
I would have sex
because it sounds like you're a little
bit too obsessed with them if I'm honest
with you no no no I can assure you I'm
not I know what I like and I don't like
fat blubbery show-offs who look hideous
dressed in Lacy pants with their fats
spilling out everywhere and doing it in
front of as many people as possible to
gain attention I just don't find that
sexy I'm old-fashioned
why on Earth are you friends with beers
Morgan
well you'll notice that you'll notice of
course that Piers hasn't appeared on
this show naked with nipple tassels
there isn't it yes again I want to quote
the pope again because the pope has done
this documentary are you a Catholic do
you think we're not but I think it's
wrong
so the pope said that to express
yourself sexually is a richness and
anything that detracts from real sexual
expression lessens you and depletes that
richness but he's not doing this for
sexual expressions
just go back to clutching your pearls
um Douglas are we look are we misreading
the room here are there millions of
young people around the world watching
this thinking he's the hottest thing on
a stage anywhere in the world right now
and we should just get used to it
uh no no I don't think so at all uh uh
and no gay guys I know are attracted to
this everyone thinks it's just kind of
ugly and stupid and it's attention
grabbing and much more I I think Sam
Smith's a person of limited Talent
myself I don't much care for his voice
but the point is is that of course he
just kind of goes around and tries to
make headlines and as I say he's pretty
successful at doing that uh but I don't
think anyone finds it sexy I don't know
any woman who finds it sexy I don't know
any gay man who finds it sexy most gay
men I know are attracted to men because
they're men Sam Smith by the way is he's
always trying to cop off with people
like Tom Daly and things I don't think
you can speak simple gay men to be
honest those are pretty much your own
words from things I've heard you say
before you can't speak for an entire
community no no I don't I don't try to I
don't believe there's any such thing as
a gay community or an lgbtqia plus I
think actually if you think this show is
effective or anything onto my stand-up
show because compared to that Sam
Smith's tour is a love letter to
Christianity and Jesus really so I'll
see you at my tour starts tomorrow I did
it I I didn't know you were touring but
good luck with that thank you yeah you
know what James best of luck with the
tour you're never going to persuade me
and clearly not Douglas either that Sam
Smith is anything other than an
attention seeker because but this whole
debate is attention seeking isn't being
an artist about attention seeking it
could be but when you're just going to
that kind of length just to be
deliberately slobishly offensive I think
it's unacceptable you're doing what you
would say islavishly offensive you're
doing that right now by saying vulgar
things about Sam Smith and deliberately
but I'm not wearing a seat enough it
doesn't matter
and send me naked it's like and once
again if you act in a vulgar way you
should expect people to be vulgar about
you I think that's the point if you're
going to do what he does it's been like
Madonna you know when she says stop
objectify me what else are we supposed
to do with them given that all she ever
does is demand we objectively you know
what you're both CIS white straight man
you can carry on I'm not assist anything
right
what did you just say if you just want
to both be when I was born
lately
wait a second what did he just say what
did you call us repeat it says you were
both I can't remember to be honest I
think you said okay why don't you shut
up
I I think you said we're both CIS white
straight men first of all I am white
secondly I am a man thirdly I've been
out and gay my entire adult life which
is about 25 years now
I was I was out as gay when you were
still prancing around talking about
whether or not you were so do be quiet
do stop judging other people and if I
owe you mean
I'm sorry I got your sexuality wrong no
if I were you I would do the tiniest bit
of research before opening your mouth
you're embarrassing yourself that's
probably why people would I don't think
so all right embarrassing yourself shame
to the queen you know what I tell you
who's really embarrassing themselves
herself themselves whatever Jesus Sam
Smith um on that note we'll leave it
thank you both very much for the picture
of sexy Sam
feeling very harmonious evening uh well
on censored next uh a more serious issue
the Afghan pilot who flew combat
missions for Britain against the Taliban
he now faces deportation to Rwanda after
coming here on one of the little boats
we'll debate that next
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you uh every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
thank you
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
well as an image we've become all too
familiar with hundreds of people crammed
onto small boats crossing the channel
the government is using hotels and even
container ships to house tens of
thousands of people as they wait for
Asylum claims to be processed it wants
to send illegal migrants to Rwanda as a
deterrent but one man now facing
deportation in that manner is an Afghan
war veteran who flew combat missions
against the Taliban with us
they only have one way to enter the UK
and that turned out to be on a small
boat he's now facing deportation
to Rwanda
he says he's been forgotten by the
people he worked alongside and a
campaign to stop his deportation through
his gathering strength had been driven
by The Independent Newspaper and has a
back of a number of senior military
figures and now this program too is
joining the fight to get Justice for
this hero well joining me now is a
little done in the former head of the
British army as a nurse his support for
the campaign and Jordy gray
editor-in-chief of the independent
welcome to both of you Jordy I read this
and it's been building for several weeks
your campaign you've had a lot of great
names getting behind it and the more you
read the more incensed you become about
what's happened to this guy but also the
more you realize that there's a lot more
to some of these stories on the small
boats than the public probably realized
because this is a hero he fought 30
missions for the Afghan Air Force
alongside British and American forces we
promised we would save those people who
offered their lives to potentially be
sacrificed in their and our fight
against the Taliban for democracy for
values which we thought were worth
fighting for now he's in a place in
Britain being threatened with
deportation without being forced by
handcuffs by armed police taking him on
board a plane to go to Rwanda after we
promised we would save them he is
actually even got the official
permission process begun this thing
called Arab which we promised those who
go through that will be protected and
looked after Britain gave its word we
cannot allow him to Feel Victim to a
what will be called a bureaucratic
mistake but actually for him could be
disaster and he had to leave in a hurry
after that catastrophic evacuation led
by the Americans Joe Biden ordered there
and it was obviously we saw the
horrendous scenes on television and amid
all the chaos there was no safe Easy
Legal route for him to take to this
country it was even worse than that
appears so at the independent pointed
out that people who had to get the
permission this arak document they had
to go to a government office manned by
the planet Taliban right I mean the
horror who if they'd know what he'd been
doing they'd kill them oh he would be
under threat he's already had threats
from him he's got a family who is at
risk is he married he's a married with a
child we can't identify they're back in
Afghanistan they're in Afghanistan I
mean it is a complete failure of our
moral duty as a country we bring in Lord
Dana Lord from your perspective what do
you think about this
well peers
um just put this in perspective in July
2021 that was a month before our
precipitate departure from Kabul and
Afghanistan I wrote an open letter
supported by 43 service Chiefs to the
government to say we have got to do
better we've got to do more and we've
got to do more quickly for those Afghans
who have stood shoulder to shoulder with
us in the fights against the Taliban and
we got a pretty mediocre response to be
honest from pretty Patel and Ben Wallace
who were the two ministers who replied
to my letter so frankly there is no
doubt at all that someone like this
Afghan Lieutenant this pilot who has
thrown 30 missions on behalf of the
Afghan nation and in support of Allied
Forces he absolutely deserves our
protection and the thought that he could
be extradited sent away in handcuffs to
Rwanda is is just appalling um it's a
different issue about that policy but as
far as this Chap's concerned he has
earned his Spurs he has earned his
ticket to stay in this country and his
family should be coming across to spend
their life their future life in peace
and security with us in this country and
we should be grateful to them Jordy a
lot of people have been supporting you
um I read Bear Grylls it gave a really
stunning I think um
support for your campaign what about
Rishi sunec because ultimately as prime
minister he can probably decide this
this man's fate have you tried directly
to contact him well we had a letter
written directly to Rishi sunak by this
hero
who we are waiting for a reply the
letter we published it couldn't have
been more clear it was a ask him if he
was going to keep the word of Britain
and we need to hear back there's been
some talk that he he passed it on to the
home office to look into we know this
that's not good it's bureaucratic fudge
I interviewed Rishi at number 10 I think
he's a decent guy I think that I hope if
he's watching this now and if not we're
going to send it to him I hope prime
minister did the right thing this man is
a hero who helped us take on the Taliban
his family are in Afghanistan we have a
moral compulsion as a country to save
this man and to take care of him and to
take care of his family you have got a
big new development on this in your
paper tomorrow we've got tomorrow's
front page of the of the independent
where he's been backed by Harry's Prince
Harry's friend former colleague the
former Marine Ben McBain yeah I had him
on the show yeah yeah who says we've got
to do what we said we'd do which is keep
our word to keep the people who fought
to keep us safe we will keep them safe
it's as simple as that
you know Harry can't you get him
involved too I probably can't ring him
tonight
um but no I'm sure that actually I've
always given Harry dude credit for his
service to his country in Afghanistan
and I think that if if he is aware of
this I would like him to get involved
and to support this because to me I'll
bring Lord dannett back here you know
Harry very well I'd imagine that would
be helpful any pressure I guess right
now from anyone high profile he's got
any connection with the military
particularly if they've served in
Afghanistan I would imagine might help
it appears you're absolutely right and
I'm sure Harry would be delighted to do
that but to be honest I think where
we've got to through George's campaign
from the Independent and just the
outrage that this issue has caused I
would be very surprised if vicious hunak
um or Ben Wallace doesn't push this one
through the whole policy of sending
Asylum Seekers back to Rwanda is can be
altered by ministerial discretion
frankly this is an issue that is so
clear so obvious we have a moral
obligation to this young Afghan pilot
Lieutenant that they should use that
discretion now they should announce it
publicly and also quietly say that his
family will come here as well frankly if
people don't have confidence on overseas
operations when they support the British
forces that we will look after them why
on Earth will they look after us we'll
be left in foreign countries dithering
away in languages we don't understand
um to goodness sake we'll need them yeah
I mean my brothers you know he said
served in Afghanistan he was a colonel
over there and he you know he he's
incensed about this he thinks that we've
let all these people down and so I know
he would be vociferously supporting this
having people like Lord dammit Former
Defense chief of the defense staff and
MC earned in Belfast served in Kosovo
served in Iraq these are these are
people who fought for our country and
they don't come and support these things
lightly unless they think this is
supporting people who supported them
when they LED our army to do things
which were necessary for the betterment
of the world for the maintenance of of
democracy and the fight for Freedom this
is an important battle and we really
appreciate it because you coming on
board with it with well I'm giving you
the full support of this show uh because
I think it is a really important battle
it may be one man but it actually
represents a large number of people who
sacrifice a lot many of them sacrifice
their lives and he can't go back now
because the Taliban will hunt him down
and they'll kill him and he must be
terrified about what's going to happen
to his family so Geordie it's a great
campaign I'm happy to lend my support to
it we're going to keep we're going to
keep hammering away at number 10 and
hopefully we'll get some good news
sooner rather than later thank you thank
you and lordana thank you very much as
always for coming on the program and
giving your support to it
good to see you yeah well I'm appears
and and uh best wishes to your brother
thank you he always speaks as you know
very highly of you so I will do that
it'll be it'll be tough thank you very
much bless you
well it says the next Dance Like An
Egyptian absolutely not it's culturally
insensitive of course it is everything
is we're debating that next
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
well coming up on the talk Rishi soon at
Boris Johnson and Liz Trust share what
might just be the world's most awkward
dinner in Belfast Fergie proves she is
still part of the firm as she gets an
invitation to the coronation concert so
is she taking Harry's ticket as he snubs
the event and Rebecca vardy has
trademarked wagatha Christie so she can
cash in that's all at nine
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
it certainly has been tonight hasn't it
well I'm joined by Kevin McGuire and
Emily server welcome to both of you
lovely to see you both um just on that
last that last uh story there this
Afghan war hero it's very interesting to
me that amid all this story is about the
people trying on the boats the Albanian
economic workers and so on I just want
an easy time here you get stories like
that which really touch you and you
realize that some of these people are
genuinely desperate and deserving people
who should be in this country more than
half the people who get across the
channel are given leaves to stay right
we've done it we've shut off the legal
routes to try and keep them out but I'll
be surprised if you don't have a review
of his case by tomorrow night well I
shall be tweeting it to about eight and
a half million people which tends to
have a little effect on uh number 10
when we do that because I do think it's
completely outrageous let's talk about
cultural appropriation Emily so a dance
troupe for female pensioners has been
forbidden from performing in sombreros
and Pharaoh costumes by Germany's
national Garden Show after being accused
of cultural insensitivity now the the
awwo ballet performing since the 80s
they're a charity for the elderly
disabled to give women in their 60s most
of them are widows and Outlet to
socialize and does what is going on
I don't listen I worked in the fashion
industry for many years cultural
appropriation was definitely happening
there you had a completely white
industry taking uh Black Culture and
selling it for a lot of money and and
they were the ones taking them but what
is wrong with the cultural cultural
appropriation not here this is
ridiculous they thought a sombrero was
going to be insulting
warning a show by some lovely old ladies
and I never think I never think the
people who we presume from these stories
are supposed to be offended would be
remotely offended I've never I've been
in Mexico many times I've never seen
anyone in Mexico be offended by tourists
wearing sombreros so Kevin yeah why we
why can't we rename it cultural
celebration why does everything have to
be immediately offensive yeah well
blackface is certainly offensive they're
not doing that yeah one time people used
to put a sombrero on a widow dancing in
a charity no because we'll be allowed to
wear ponchos I mean the only good thing
is this festival's now moved them up on
the main stage where does this line
derived I think I think it's not bad to
be aware and be respectful and question
but every now and again if you're going
to do that just as you get ignorant
people who trample all over others
you'll get people who are over sensitive
and then make a mistake and this just
feels like the problem is Emily I just
think this is creeping thing where once
you give in to any of these things it
never stops it never stops once you've
established cultural appropriation not a
day goes by without somebody somewhere
falling foul of culturally appropriating
someone's I literally don't think that
someone that they haven't looked up what
cultural appropriation is and the roots
of it so I just think it's people sort
of in a sort of panic oh my God if we do
this we're going to get in lots and lots
of trouble they're not doing any
research they're not actually working
out what is cultural appropriation what
isn't yeah so it's just sort of why
can't you why can't you celebrate other
cultures well you can but would you say
it was okay to Black up as a Jamaican I
don't know
certainly don't think that blackface is
acceptable so there is a limit so you've
agreed of course I'm not saying there's
no limit yeah but widows wearing a
sombrero no they've got it wrong here
it's ridiculous you're right you're
right the organizer got it right as I've
said I do think the white fashion
industry definitely at times was
stealing a black New York Street culture
right and they weren't seeing any of the
money and in some cases one big fashion
group actually had to pay a black street
culture guy because they quite literally
stole his designs without paying that's
wrong yeah there are limits yeah I don't
think anyone disputes that and also I
think intent is important yeah you're
intending to be offensive right yeah so
if you if you're deliberately culturally
offensive to another culture if you're
mocking a culture that's one thing I
mean if you're celebrating it it's a
totally different thing I think we've
lost that ability to draw a line between
celebration and inappropriate
appropriation yeah right uh can do
sometimes but I think it's it's not bad
to be aware and challenge uh and if a
load of Mexicans turn up or Japanese or
Egyptians turn up and they're offended
then I think they should be listened to
and not laughed
and I know it hasn't happened but I
subscribed to the Ricky gervaising which
is someone's always going to be offended
somewhere about something don't be
offended anyway if you're a Mexican and
there's some nice old ladies wearing
some sombreros I don't think it would be
I agree everyone's sombreros when we go
to Mexico I'm I'm Irish on St Patrick's
Day when everyone dresses up in green
and leprechauns and stuff I don't run
around going saying I'm offended I am I
say where's my Guinness no I don't mind
if someone who dresses up as a as Tower
Bridge or whatever remarks us as British
I don't understand why you would be
offended but I can sometimes see people
who had a lot of abuse then will feel
there's a line but it's as with all woke
things it's just gone ridiculous um
let's go to woke language so
um we're now being told apparently that
Boots the chemists they changed the word
less abled well they changed from
disabled to Less abled on a parking side
can I talk about this please because as
someone who had a disabled nephew yeah
sorry where why is less Ables better
than distance yes I think it's shocking
I think it's it's like the Roald Dahl
censorship when you can call someone fat
you could call them gigantic you're
saying someone is less able I think it's
more insulting than disable We There are
some words we do need to change and
rethink quite a number of them but to
replace them with something which I
think is worse but what about the
national what about the National
Institute for Health and Care Excellence
I've asked NHS staff to refer to
alcoholics as people who misuse alcohol
I don't mind that so much why because
less because they are misusing alcohol
less and they're also alcoholics they're
also out colleagues it's like when you
say you can't call fat people fat well
they're fat they're not gonna they're
not gonna get fat I know but by the way
when people say to me you're looking a
bit fat I go to the gym more I kind of
lose a bit of weight and they go you've
lost a bit of Timber and it feels good I
guess I mind less about that I think
boots saying someone is less able is
deeply deeper I can't see people going
to meetings or people misusing Alcohol
Anonymous I think it'll just go
some of the others some of the others
Kevin some of the others they also asked
this National Institute the staff to
refer to drug addicts is people who use
drugs smokers as people who smoke rough
sleepers there's people who experience
homelessness as if any of this matters
to these people these are the NHS this
is the National Institute for Health and
Care Excellence these are definitions
NHS stuff yeah but here's my point none
of these people care about being called
these things this is some woke
rewriting language for people who don't
either know or care I've never heard a
single smoker how dare you dare you call
me a person
it's covering up much more serious
issues they've just had all these
stories this week of the NHS where
people are being raped in hospitals and
we're talking and they're being advice
that's the point the wokies they get
these ludicrous things Amplified and it
Smothers oh real stories yes peers peers
come on let's just go back a bit at one
time used to talk about handicapped
people you're no longer well you're no
longer going to be called the peers pack
you're going to be people who identify
as hackers okay that's it just in case
either of you are offended great to see
you both that's it from me what a nice
what a show whatever you're up to keep
it like this so uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no uh with the people's
Channel no what are you every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it well that one too
[Music]
questions
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
foreign
politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it